Governor DeSantis responded to Igor's
comments I was sorry to see us
dragged into that battle
and I have no idea exactly what its
ramifications are in terms of the
business itself what I can say is the
state of Florida has been important to
us for a long time and we have been very
important to the State of Florida that
is something I'm extremely mindful of
and will articulate if I get the chance
how do you respond to that he's talking
about you
we didn't drag them in Tucker they went
in on their own and not only opposed the
bill they threatened to get it repealed
these are parents rights important
policies in our state that are very
popular and so they brought this on
themselves all we did was stand up for
what's right and yes they're a big
powerful company but you know what we
stand up for our folks yeah yeah the
scientists didn't choose this thing they
basically Disney basically said we're
gonna get rid of DeSantis because of
this don't say gay bill that doesn't
even have the word gay in it but you
know me I've got a backbone like a
ramrod
and I even said the word gay to DeSantis
back in June all right so first off we
have to start with the obvious one
gay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
he didn't even flinch
so why did this anthis fight why did he
choose the fight which again the people
of Florida
clearly like without question have said
you were on the right side of this fight
why did he do it because he was voted in
to protect Floridians and the rights of
the people that live here he was not
voted in to defend Disney or
corporations or globalist Empires or
anything else he also told me a bit
about that but I think Disney took it
one step further when they put out this
incredible statement after they already
did all their virtue signaling after we
signed the bill saying this was somehow
a violation of Human Rights and that
they would work to see that parents
rights and education were repealed
through the legislature and I'm just
thinking to myself
um you know I took a note to support the
laws and Constitution of the U.S and the
State of Florida I did not take an oath
to subcontract out my leadership to a
corporation based in Burbank California
they don't run the this state
guys this is how we win the culture war
and ultimately win the political war and
ultimately win the war on freedom look I
know that the the Red Wave did not
happen the way some of us would have
liked that's political racehorse stuff
and it's hard to figure out sometimes
why people vote the way they vote but
the culture War which then leads to why
people vote a certain way right it's a
generational thing uh if you can start
winning on that and there are wins right
the santis beat Disney Then crushed in
the election here Elon beat Twitter and
that Twitter tried to stop him from
buying it now he's got it and he's
fighting the freaking machine and
Republicans now for the first time in a
long time are standing alongside of him
right what's that Kevin McCarthy video
that I showed you all about we are
standing beside this guy sometimes if
you do the right thing like DeSantis if
you do the right thing like Elon you
start making other people a little
braver to do the right thing as well
that's the ripple effect and it and it
takes time and I think that means that
right now we have a certain moment that
that could be really transcendent